Treasure Planet just saying that name
sounds kind of silly and I'm not gonna
lie that's sort of the major issue I
have with this movie its Treasure Island
only we're not telling it like most
people tell Treasure Island we're
telling it in space in the future but
the spaceships aren't really spaceships
they're water
ships but the people are dressed
futuristically at least some of them the
ones not wearing bonnets and okay let's
start from the beginning
a young Jim Hawkins hears about the
legend of buried treasure only like we
said before it's not a treasure island
it's on Treasure Planet years go by and
Jim Hawkins it turns out is now a
delinquent always getting in trouble and
feeling bad that his father left Wow is
that really in a Disney film no car
accident no tragic death he actually
just up and left wow that's actually
pretty rare well anyway his mother has a
hard enough time trying to raise him
while also trying to look after a
restaurant but all that changes when he
comes across a treasure map their
treasure sphere whatever that apparently
shows them the location of Treasure
Planet he comes across one of his
mother's friends called dr. dopler
and he recommends that they find a ship
and go looking for the treasure
the mother kind of bizarre Lee agrees
and thus Jim and Doppler are off on
adventure the captain this time around
is a cat lady no I don't mean she likes
cats I mean literally she's half cat
half lady played by Emma Thompson the
cook is John Silver played by Brian
Murray and he also comes across a few
other little friends like this little
glob of goo named morph a robot voiced
by Martin Short and all sorts of other
weird oddities okay so what's good about
the movie goes actually there are a lot
of good things about it first of all it
gets down what I think really any Disney
film should get down first
the relationships with the characters
for example the relationship between
Hawkins and his mother is great
relationship between him and John Silver
is great the relationship between dopler
and the captain is great and to the
film's credit the reason the
relationships are so great is because
all the characters are pretty darn good
too Hawkins is sort of your generic
rebellious hero but
at the same time they do leave it open
for people to leave impressions on him
he will absorb what people are telling
him and that's a good trade for a
character the captain is a lot of fun
she's very dignified very intelligent
but she's also a fast talker and likes
to show off dopler at times can get
annoying and yeah I'm not a fan of the
Martin Short robot but he's not infinite
Long John Silver is great as the
character should be both being
diabolical but also having a soft side
for Hawkins so okay it seems to follow
the book pretty well the characters are
strong what's actually wrong with this
film that seems like the most important
stuff well as I said before it's the
setting why is this set in the future
okay let me point this way you can set
it in the future that's fine but go all
out if you want to show a spaceship show
a spaceship some cool looking ones when
you just have giant boats in space
that's all we're gonna see you have
futuristic parasailing in the sky but
then you also had people in 19th century
dress honestly it's just distracting
sometimes it really works like all the
mechanics on John Silver instead of just
having a fake leg he has a fake arm a
fake eye and all of its technologically
advanced that's pretty cool I just wish
the rest of the movie went that far
instead of trying to create this world
that they just want to create on its own
they kept trying to combine it with what
was popular what was advanced and then
what was also sir true of the time
period the book was written and that
just sort of turns out a cluttered mess
and I don't think it's a pet peeve
because it's constantly distracting I'm
always asking how do these two things go
together these are two totally different
time periods that really have almost
nothing to do with one another you can
borrow some things but this is really
weird on top of that the same way that
something like Oliver and company felt
very manipulative you know like half the
visuals was something a marketing agent
came up with yeah you feel that
throughout the entire movie I mean it
opens with sky surfing all I could think
of was that opening in the Power Rangers
movie where they go sky surfing - it's
like really look you can relate with Jim
Hawkins he's doing cool stuff ooh
he wears a short black jacket he has a
cool haircut he's got a ponytail rad he
goes to his mother who looks like
something out of
dick wait what so yeah I wasn't on board
with the idea I constantly felt like I
was being manipulated and really I
wanted to see Disney do Treasure Island
no gimmicks no whatever's cool at the
time just tell Treasure Island
so I guess my final sum up is when they
do tell Treasure Island yeah it's good
and when they tried to do something cool
and hip it's lame sometimes the sci-fi
designs Arnie but mostly it's just
distracting I don't know if you can look
at these visuals and they don't bother
you in fact you actually find yourself
getting into it but you'll probably like
this movie fine for me it just
constantly took me out of it and I would
like to have seen the original source
material really come to life as told by
Disney but it's not horrible it's not
even really that bad I could just never
get into it as much as the movie wants
me to get into it hopefully you can draw
your own conclusions and you can see if
this movie is worth your time
you